my father is the hero endeavor
he's the number-two hero and you're
mentally reciting this to yourself
because you might forget who your father
is it was this internal narration for so
if you are somehow connected to all
might the number-one hero then that
would mean I have even more reason to be
you for reasons in every memory of my
mother I only see her crying sob story
narration wah where Asian I'm going to
show my old man that I don't have to
rely on his damned firework I'm going to
show him that I reject his power and
who's going to show me the catch me up
log cuz holy I have been dropped
directly into the middle of some episode
comprised of nearly 83 percent hero
stands stoic Lee still glancing
wistfully upward with the wind blowing
in their hair cliches like say flake boy
dammit nobody will be seated during the
various superheroes casually stretch and
warm up instead of doing actual hero
stuff during the opening credits portion
of the episode cat pipes look animation
styles and anime are perfectly fine as
long as you're not attached to human
characters always having noses like I
said perfectly fun do you want to burn
your retinas because staring into the
Sun is how you burn your retinas honey
you do still want to be a hero don't you
just remember stay true to yourself I
mean your mom looks pretty happy in the
scene and you were the one crime pretty
strange considering you just said your
only memories of your mother were her
crying okay I usually start with pilots
on TV sins but someone told me this is
one of the most liked episodes of the
show I'm now three minutes in and
looking at a lineup of pickaxe chin
European outlet mouth and stapler
remover head man and I haven't been this
loss since I tried to walk in here and
face what the hell is going on with this
guy's mouth someone get this man some
chapstick stats this is horrible Stadium
design these Jumbotrons are more micro
than jumbo and how is anyone even
supposed to see anything on them when
they're that high in the air
also what is with all the wasted space
between the stands and the top of the
stadium were they trying to build the
least efficient arena possible it's good
to see that this event was attended by
schoolgirl Legolas human Sesame Street
and Seth Meyers
now I'm getting it these kids have
powers and they're fighting each other
to see who's number one we have hair
flair versus finger flick and my only
question at this point is if finger
flick breaks a bone when he launches
boogers or ants or paper footballs
there's anything more ridiculous than
the things random anime crowds say I've
yet to hear it wait what is Captain
America doing here but the time travel
through the quantum roam land him in
this reality no I'm thinking of the time
travel holes in endgame and that's
certainly worth another set he's
prepared to injure himself to counter me
I'm going to inner dialogue the entire
battle because I'm already sick of it
and we aren't even emitted into this
random superpower cluster fight so he
abandoned restraint and fired off a shot
at a hundred percent this fight last so
being alone like it goes on for 16 more
minutes Zuka does not give a hundred
percent now he does that later and I
hate you for giving me false hope that
this is almost over Oh God
you still have thumbs toes a cheek and
maybe a core to all of which you can
flick for a price nobody but you was
worried here buddy hi yes there is
nothing more intense than a battle where
the same exact thing happens several
times and by the same exact thing I mean
deflecting a nice attack with your
finger I haven't seen fingering this
dangerous since the movie fear yes sure
in your dreams so people like the show
on ironically cuz that character just
used in your dreams as a comeback and a
pretty sure that was outlawed in the US
after the Sidney Prescott cliche trials
in the late 90s if you overuse your
muscles you risk tearing them apart
correct that's the whole point it's
called working out do you even lift bro
also are the fighters just waiting all
this sidelines conversation is happening
we all have a limits how much power we
can produce can't relate I have
unlimited power to sin feel my wrath you
want an endurance match but I'll end
this quickly he won't but I wish he
would this show last airbender is so
hard I'm half expecting an annoying kid
with an arrow tattoo to show up and ride
a sky snuffleupagus
that was much more powerful than any of
your previous attacks though I'm not
sure how I'm supposed to tell what beats
what or how any of this works how many
ice shards before it defeats the finger
banks can I just get the
rock-paper-scissors cheat sheet so at
least I know who's winning or how the
silly game is played
better than the average Pro wait is this
an amateur match they fill stadiums like
this for the amateurs you see I'm going
to show that bastard that I reject his
power and take first place without
losing yes we know in the nine minutes
of this episode you've literally
mentioned it four times already
there's no way fights this repetitive
and boring and talky draw these kinds of
crowds especially in a world where so
many people have these quirks also if
your fingers are broken and you really
shouldn't be able to make a fist finger
flicker feigning finger fractures feels
fake like a tease usually you'd make up
for the drop in temperature by using the
heat oh my god just skip me skipping
into my skip oh shut up and fight you
haven't managed to put a single scratch
on me yes sure technically broken body
parts aren't scratches is the reason you
have a broken arm and busted hand do you
think you can win with half your
strength if it wasn't bad enough that
these two won't stop talk fighting the
show commits the cardinal sin of
repeating the last twenty seconds from
before the commercial break here's a sin
for every repeat at second you made me
sit through twice in the microwave Sutra
wait is this stadium falling why are
their intensity lines on the sides of
the static shot of the stance what am I
even watching here midoriya knows that
recovery girl will heal his wounds after
the match is there any part of the
episode that isn't blatantly spoken
exposition why are you putting yourself
through this because the fans wanted me
to send this goddamn show and honestly I
should have said no I regret everything
ignore them shows they live in a
different world than the one I'm
training you for you know what's great
about this show it's just like the x-men
if their unique superpowers were just
different forms of narrated exposition
ham-fisted flashbacks and occasionally
punching each other in slow-motion
there are so many trigger warnings in
the three minutes of Scarface's back
store child abuse spouse abuse more
child abuse the show finally decides to
show substance and it's this brutal yeah
well back to the neverending fight where
they don't actually fight I'll be a hero
well you've got to be strong and you've
got to be fast and you got to be fresh
from the fight can you do that
also are you really a hero by winning
tournaments is that heroic seems like
wasted powers and pointless dangerous
combat that helps no-one and improves
nothing the true heroes are the ones out
in the street saving people from
watching the show you will live
to the reason I created you dance what's
happening here
she ripping her clothes or her body can
release healing by revealing her skin is
healing in her arm how about her nipples
what happens if you rip that cloth what
that's a valid question
oh look after 20 minutes of talking to
themselves and dancing around something
finally happened god help me I have no
idea what but hooray for something I'm
impressed you are an excellent
waterbender I can't be scared old
mobster so that felt big they are
flame flames flames on the side of my
face you see
I'm going to show that bastard that I
reject his power and take first place
without losing it am I talking too much
yes why don't you kiss instead of
cognitive death hold me closer tiny
dancer there's a headlight on the
highway Woodrow tiny dancer